all right
this is uh the reason live stream I'm
Nick Gillespie and today I am talking
with Elizabeth Nolan Branch who's a
recent senior editor and I'm talking
with Scott Winship of the American
Enterprise Institute where he's a senior
fellow and the director of the center on
opportunity and social Mobility uh Scott
Liz thanks for talking to reason
hi thanks for having me all right so
today what we are talking about is one
of you know there's the AI Panic uh but
there's a deeper longer lived kind of uh
rolling Panic which probably has
something to do with AI as well but
that's fears that we are not producing
enough children particularly in the U.S
but this is something uh that comes and
goes and waves all over the globe uh
particularly in Western Europe
um excuse me
um you know uh 50 years ago uh or
thereabouts the uh obviously the fear
was that we were having too many
children uh particularly in bad parts of
the world by which I mean third world
countries China India and that we were
going to be overrun by poor starving
people uh who would be pissed off now
the problem is that even in those
countries we're seeing declining
fertility rates and this has given rise
to a new uh conversation about how do we
uh how do we increase uh fertility rates
or the number of children that women
have Liz uh Nolan Brown in the most
recent issue of Reason uh has a great
story called storks don't take order
it's from the state at first I thought
this was of last you know the
long-awaited flastic pickle special
issue that we've been talking about
um but it's not that
um but let's start with uh Liz give a
basic summary of what what is your story
about
what did you say
it's about falling fertility rates in
the in the U.S and around the world
pretty much
um you know more than half of the
countries in the world have below
replacement level fertility which is 2.1
uh kids per woman
um some of them quite a bit below the
United States is at 1.66 which puts us
kind of kind of on par with uh with a
whole lot of uh European countries and
um above above a lot of um of the very
low countries
um so it sort of looks at why fertility
rates have been falling a little bit of
the good reasons for that but also the
negative things associated with that
um it looks at a lot of the theories as
to why fertility rates are falling and
then sort of
tears them all apart because when you
look at the global data it doesn't
really lend itself to any of this sort
of popular explanations that come from
either the right or the left of the
United States
what um yeah what are the you know and
again this is when we know we're in a
full-blown panic because people on the
right and the left sometimes for the
same reasons but us often for you know
different reasons are like oh my God
this is now officially an issue um
typically if it's just the writer it's
just the left you're like okay we're you
know we're in the gestation period I'm
sorry to use pregnancy related metaphors
throughout this conversation but uh you
know it's like okay this is just for
cheap political opportunity but this now
has you know it's entered the
bloodstream right because both the right
and the left are like oh my God we're
not having enough babies what is the um
you know what was your main finding of
because this is a global phenomenon
um and it's something that is actually I
mean if you take a longer view it's like
basically for hundreds of years uh in
general there's been a very broadly
observed correlation that as countries
become richer and more industrialized
they have fewer kids but what what is
driving the decline in birth rights
I think the the main findings were two
things um neither of which answers your
question what is driving the decline
because that's that's sort of a mystery
unless we just say individual choice in
general
um but the main findings I think were
that you know pronatalist policies
government policies intended to boost
birth rates don't work whether that's
you know bribing people to have more
kids with you know various uh tax
incentives or direct cash payments or
all sorts of subsidies or just sort of
uh patriotic campaigns like Russia gave
people like several days off work to
like make babies
um none of that works and then the other
main finding is that uh yeah like I said
just you know a lot of these
explanations you have you know on the
right things like we're not valuing
motherhood enough or too many women are
working or um you know we just haven't
we you know there's all these selfish
single Millennial women who don't want
to have kids and are being childless and
on the left you have all these you know
more economic explanations we need more
government subsidies for child care we
need it's just true
yeah and when you look at other
countries these these things just don't
not none of these explanations really
pan out right because in some countries
you know women are given a lot of money
to have kids and others they're not and
there just doesn't seem to be a strong
correlation correct between that and one
of the things in your story that is
available online at reason.com uh points
out is you know there was a kind of
plausible uh notion that you know with
the baby boom after World War II women
kind of let left the workforce from a a
certain Peak during the War years
because everybody was working you know
either fighting or working in factories
when they pulled out of the labor force
a little bit they had more kids and and
people were like oh this is the thing
but then uh as women entered the work
you know at various points women
entering the workforce they had fewer
kids or they enter the workforce even
more and they have more kids so it's
just the day to really you know the the
only thing we know for sure is that
women are having fewer kids yeah
basically yeah and Scott your work uh
and and I really want to recommend
everything that you do at the direct uh
at the center on opportunity and social
Mobility I'm a big fan of it of your
work particularly because then we've
talked at various times over the years
about it you stand a thwart decline
narratives or declension narratives
where people are saying things are just
going to hell in a handbasket you say
you know no not really one of your
findings is that you know one of the
reasons why we're having fewer children
is because women want fewer children
what goes into that
yeah I think that's right I think if you
if you look at the Grand sweep of
History
um was Liz's uh piece mentions this you
know there's there's been this I don't
know over a hundred year decline in
fertility with the exception of the baby
boom that we can sort of come back to uh
which I think is a more interesting
story than a lot of people realize
um but but yeah essentially apart from
the baby boom and then you know small
recovery more recently before the Great
Recession uh it's just been down and and
fertility dropped the most during the
1970s which not coincidentally at all
was the big decade for women's labor
force participation Rising
um that was you know the generation of
of Boomer uh women who had opportunities
that opened up uh that weren't there
before
um coincides with increasing educational
attainment on the part of women later
marriage
more divorce
um and and as Liz's piece notes you know
these are sort of trends that are common
to rich countries around the world uh
it's it's kind of modernity
um uh and at the same time that we've
seen these declines in fertility you
know there is empirical evidence
suggesting that women want fewer kids
than they that they did the past uh so I
wrote a piece
um boy I guess a couple years ago at
this point which is crazy
um uh where it actually asked people
when they had asked women when they were
in their late teens uh how many kids do
you expect to have
um in in one of the surveys how many
kids do you want to have and that's gone
down over time it's basically gone down
you know in line with how much actual
fertility has gone down
um this this was sort of comparing the
youngest or the the youngest boom
Farmers to the oldest Millennials
um so essentially what we're looking at
is I I think
um a change in preferences and uh it
will have consequences I think that uh
that Liz talks about
um but but we tend to forget you know if
if the decline is the result of
preferences for fewer kids that's a very
different story and it implies benefits
that have to be weighed against these
costs than if the story is well people
want the same number of kids it's just
they can't afford to have them anymore
yeah and this was yeah go ahead people
will always point to these surveys that
you know will show still Millennial and
genetics women saying you know the ideal
number of children is two but I think
you know as I talk about in there too um
you know a lot of those surveys get are
asked when people are fairly young and
you know people change like surveys do
show that when people are younger they
tend to say they want more kids and then
that changes when they get older because
you know
and then it's yeah and then it's
difficult or expensive or they just get
other priorities in their life or you
know something doesn't work out in their
marriage just a billion different
reasons why people might you know when
their 20s say they want four kids and
then by the time they're third you
realize they don't and that doesn't mean
that they failed in their fertility
goals it just means change their mind
yeah it is please yeah these questions
you know get posed to 18 year olds um
without any kind of like trade-offs
right they're not like all right what
would you give up to have the two kids
that you that you would like to have are
you willing to
um you know live in a less glamorous uh
suburb uh with a smaller house uh so
that you can save up more uh to afford
these kids and give up are you willing
to spend 20 years watching Nickelodeon
and whatever succeeded Disney Channel
for kids uh you know for 20 years same
episode of Phineas and Ferb over and
over and over uh and I I want to point
out for Skeptics all of us here have
done our share to keep the planet
populated which you know and I'm older
I'm older than you guys and I'm old
enough to remember when Humanity was the
problem when overpopulation was the
problem and so I feel bad I have two
children and uh you know God I I I
haven't helped the environment by uh you
know shutting down the uh my
evolutionary uh stream uh let's before
we go to the question of whether or not
there are government policies that can
actually increase fertility rates and
you know as you mentioned you know like
you know it's it's a mixed sword right
or a mixed uh message when you you say
something like even Stalin couldn't get
Russian women to have more kids because
it's like obviously the Soviet Union and
communism doesn't work it doesn't work
that you know create kids or anything
but it's kind of fascinating when a
totalitarian leader is incapable of
getting women to put out more basically
right this is you know in in the crudest
terms possible but we'll talk about
whether or not the state can do that and
whether it should but first can we focus
a little bit on the question of whether
or not it's a it you know how do you
measure the costs and benefits of
a falling fertility rate and they're you
know they're one um you know there's the
images which are older now because in
places like China and India the most
populous countries in the world uh birth
rates are declining
um and populations are aging but you
know you have that as the bad sign but
then you have uh you know in a place
like Japan which I believe is the only
country only industrialized country that
has fewer people now than in 2000 it has
a famously aging population
Etc and the economy I you know it's not
clear how tightly correlated any of this
is Japan has been in what's been called
The Lost decade for really the past 30
years almost 40 years
um but what are the negative
consequences of a decline in birth rates
or or in in population of a country
Scott do you want to go first on that
what are what are are there issues with
that
yeah so there there are a lot of claims
that are made and I'm not an expert in
this in this literature
um you know the big ones that you hear
are results in slower
um economic growth over time weirdly
that's often uh framed in terms of GDP
rather than GDP per person like if we
have fewer people uh or or the growth in
people is lower like it's okay to have a
lower growth in GDP as long as we don't
have lower growth in GDP per person
um you know there's evidence that it uh
reduces dynamism and Innovation
um entrepreneurship things like that
I think there's so there there there's
big impacts on for instance
um senior entitlements uh to the extent
that you've got a lot of retirees that
are receiving Social Security Medicare
um and you don't have a lot of people
who are paying taxes into the system
that creates some fiscal stress for sure
uh
so I I think there's in some ways some
of it is is just math I think the
entitlement problem you know is very
real others you know are empirical
questions I don't think there's
fantastic research for a lot of the
claims
um
uh yeah I think it's clear that that
regions states that um that have lower
fertility experience less dynamism than
places that don't
um but I don't that doesn't necessarily
translate I think into the future
um but those are the those are the ones
you hear I think Liz touches on all
these uh their opinions Liz you are uh
calling in from uh the uh Southwestern
Ohio region Cincinnati uh where I I
lived in Oxford for a number of years
and that part of Ohio in general but
that part of Ohio is an interesting
example of a place where you know
they're they're losing population
relative to other parts of the country
and whatnot they don't have a lot of
immigration to that you know to like the
Cincinnati Metro Area
um what what do you see as you know
you're in a part of the country which is
kind of suffering from you know uh you
know on a micro level some of the issues
where there are fewer people and the
population as a aging are there concerns
with that
um that that we should be thinking about
and taking seriously
I mean in terms of just what I see
around me I I can't really it's hard to
speak to it because Cincinnati and this
whole area that I'm in is so much more
Dynamic now than it was 20 or 30 years
ago um so it's it's kind of strange even
though the population but the lines have
the Skechers uh stores in the mall are
just out there I mean they have to
convert a lot of the Catholics
the one I went to and like five others
have all combined because there's much
fewer but I don't know if that's that
could just also be fewer people in
Catholic School than previously
Catholicism has not had a great 20 years
it has it is not yeah uh but but I like
I talked to this uh this guy from uh
Khalifa university in the United
immigrants Stuart guess Geico Boston I'm
probably butcher in his name who works
on these issues a lot and I thought his
perspective on this was really
interesting because he talks about how
you know it could be an opportunity like
lower population people focus on the
Doom aspects of it but it could be an
opportunity and at any rate it we
shouldn't just be vote like the reason
people want to raise birth rates and
they're obsessed with it is because
while population decline like instead of
focusing on make more babies make more
babies we should be looking at the
actual problems we're trying to solve
whether that's dynamism or like having
to shift where people are in the labor
you know force or whether that's you
know pension systems and old age
entitlements like and fix those problems
instead of trying to fix this proxy
problem of the birth rates because even
if we raise birth rates right now we're
still facing this massive aging
population in the US and still be other
countries and more babies right now even
aren't even gonna aren't going to change
that yeah it's uh you know Jonathan last
who was at the Weekly Standard and is
now at
um uh the dispatch or the bulwark I
apologize for confusing
uh bulwark thank you uh about 10 or 15
years ago he wrote a very good book
about this General problem called what
to expect when nobody's expecting and uh
you know kind of uh anticipating your uh
what both of you have said in different
ways it's that declining fertility
rights or declining population is the is
an artifact of modernity of people
having more money more options
particularly more women and I know he
tied declines in fertility to
essentially they correlate with the more
years of education that women have
available to them which is a proxy for
opportunity on autonomy and so it does
seem and Scott I think you even
mentioned this it's you know like
the war on declining fertility I mean if
it's going to become a war on modernity
um that's kind of disturbing but it also
seems like a lot of critics particularly
on the right seem to be like yes yes
that is exactly the problem
um how how does one reach uh you know a
person who is invested in the idea that
you know and and they they can be male
or female uh you know but saying no
women need to be making more babies for
the good of something
yeah I mean go ahead Liz oh no I'll just
I'll just some surprising things
assumptions in baked into those sort of
uh ideas are wrong like a lot of people
just uh assume that you know low
fertility rates are being driven by a
rise in childlessness of women or
couples just deciding that they that
they don't want to have kids and you
know there's a stereotype on the right
and it's just they're all you know too
selfish and too busy with either their
careers or having fun or whatever
um but actually you know we're kind of
on par with historic levels of of
childlessness actually the decline is
much more driven by people just having
smaller families there's way fewer
people having four plus kids and way
more having one or two so we've actually
got more people having
um children than than either than 30 40
years ago even uh but they're just
having smaller families than they did
Once Upon a Time
which I think puts things at a different
perspective absolutely yeah absolutely
for sure yeah no I I mean what I've been
trying to do
um really as a result of the child tax
credit expansion uh debate from a couple
of years ago is to try to force people
to just confront the facts and and I
think
um you know I have a lot of friends who
are social conservatives
um a lot of them really would like to
believe that the decline in fertility is
in large measure because uh people still
want the same number of kids they just
can't have them for some reason if
that's student loan debt if it's like
housing has gotten too expensive uh you
name it um there's some kind of economic
Factor behind it and I just don't think
the evidence is consistent with that the
paper that I wrote for the dispatch a
couple years ago showed that
um the the older Millennials are no less
likely to hit the fertility targets that
they said they were shooting for at 18
then and then the youngest Boomers were
um and actually you've found that they
were a little bit closer to yeah that's
right that's right you know Boomers or
at least Boomer women wanted more kids
than they achieved
um yeah Millennials were doing pretty
good
yeah that's exactly right and so I think
um I think social conservatives I would
hope are sort of
forced to confront this evidence that a
lot that they would they would like to
believe that the culture hasn't changed
the preferences haven't changed and
therefore there's an economic
explanation that policy such as bumping
up the child tax credit by a couple
thousand dollars increasing paid leave
uh by this or that can can move the
lever on some of this stuff because if
it's just culture and it's it's
preferences and modernity you know good
luck uh with the policy changing that I
think ultimately social conservatives
you know this this is a marketing
campaign in the end for them like if
they it's perfectly fine to want more
kids and to think Americans should be
having more kids uh but that's a value
position and you need to convince uh the
rest of the country uh to think that way
too it is fast yeah go ahead oh just
it's funny that you say that this is the
position of social conservatives too
because it's it's it's again the
convergence of the left and the right on
these things because both of them have
said it sort of settled on this idea
that like if only we could make you know
give people more money in order to raise
their kids than yeah and I want to get
to that in a second but you know just to
dilate first again I apologize
the weirdness of the baby boom and
particularly the 1950s as a decade uh
that you know I think if if you trace
the kind of um intellectual etiology of
of why do we look back in the not to the
1950s as a decade of you know all
positive stuff
um it's really Bill Bennett and William
Bennett and a bunch of social
conservatives people who are then called
neoconservatives often painted a picture
of the night they they needed to
demonize the 1960s as the decade when
everything went insane and so they
LeapFrog back over that and this was
starting in the late 70s and in the 80s
and they went you know they talked
specifically about the 1950s as this
wonderful decade it was a return to
normalcy and there was broad prosperity
and they they painted a picture in in a
series of works of of you know just a
wonderful time when women left the
workforce you know Rosie the Riveter
turned out not to be a crypto lesbian
but she really wanted to go home and
have like eight kids
um and you know Bill Bennett would talk
about how you know teachers only
complain that kids in school were
chewing gum or talking in the Halls
during classes
um and it and you know divorce rates
went down for the first time and you
know like in the past 150 or almost 200
years divorce rates have been climbing
uh you know except for in the 1950s
um and if they painted this erroneous
picture of a decade focusing on like
kind of pro Family Values moments and
then of course you know a light of the
fact that rock music came out then the
Beats were everywhere you know people
started doing drugs the Civil Rights
Movement there was so much anxiety about
you know Johnny couldn't read and
Sputnik was eating our lunch and we all
got fat
um it it Castle long Shadow because you
have people looking back at it an
incredibly atypical decade that they are
already mischaracterizing and then
saying why can't we do that I look at
you know various accounts on Twitter and
you know God forbid that we mistake
Twitter for reality but there's a
Nostalgia for a kind of Neo 50s ISM of
like where no we can really go back to
having four kids and a family and living
in cul-de-sacs
ETC as if anybody really wants that and
I think until social conservatives kind
of get over the idea that a that was
never what it was but it's not coming
back they'll be lost and then the left
you know is getting on this bandwagon of
like well we need to you know we need to
subsidize children more so that we have
more of them mostly so that they will
fund Social Security and Medicare which
should not just be for old people but
for everybody and I guess you know uh on
on the heels of that let's talk about
some of the attempts by various
governments both now and in the past to
actually increase fertility Liz what did
you find when you surveyed you know past
some present attempts by specific
societies to say okay you know what
we're going to crank up the baby making
machine
um I mean yeah I found that in short
just that it doesn't work
um that you know that some of the
countries that have tried the hardest
are South Korea which has one of the
lowest fertility rates um in the world I
think it's it's one uh 0.81 in 2021 so
it's below one now and um also Singapore
and Japan very very low Singapore's is
around 1.1 or 1.2 Singapore has tried so
much they you know they give people
preferential housing because you know a
lot of the state the housing is decided
by the state so they give you
preferential housing if they have more
kids they gave people Direct Cash
bonuses eight thousand ten thousand
dollars for a first kid more after that
they you know subsidize child care they
give subsidies to grandparents to move
nuts and their kids they've just tried
basically every everything that you can
try and um it has not managed to to
raise their fertility rate has continued
to fall over the past several decades
and that's the same story that you see
in Japan it's the same story that you
see basically everywhere that is really
you know gone all in on these sort of
pronatalist policies and and then to the
same effect some of them you know aren't
specifically portrayed as product as
policies but say like the Nordic
countries where there is like subsidized
leave a lot of you know guarantee
guaranteed parental leave subsidized
Child Care women can stay home for a
year or more after the kit and and they
also have seen you know birth rates just
continue to fall over the past several
decades
Scott do you have you found any places
where these policies either seem to work
or or they kind of pay for themselves or
or something
uh so I thought Liz's uh article did a
great job summarizing the evidence
um I've I've tended to sort of
look to some of the more pronatalist
folks out there who
um you know would love to find policies
that would move the Needle and to sort
of see what they say so I think now as
the time and the uh the conversation
that that we ring the bell and invoke
lymanstone
um you know can you explain who he is
and uh yeah so Lyman Stone
um is a demographer I think he's in grad
school right now
um uh getting an econ degree uh has
written for well he was at AEI for a
little while he has some affiliation
with the institute for family studies
um has written a lot about fertility
Trends
um and is is I think it's safe to say
he's a pronatalist I think he'd call
himself that uh he had a long Twitter
response which is kind of his modus
operandi uh to Liz's original piece when
it came out and what was interesting
about it was uh to me was that he
claimed first of all that that 99
percent of uh the well first that Liz
ignored the programs that work uh was
the first one second but 99 of what's
tried uh is to meager uh to have any
impact
um so I guess he's saying Liz missed the
one percent uh uh of studies and then
third that um you know as an example of
something
that to be clear he didn't endorse
um uh but something that could move the
needle was in Romania uh you know where
they outlawed birth control and abortion
for
yeah this was under chichasco so it's
yeah at the peak of chuchisco's uh
glorious Powers Yeah so you know for
more than a decade outlawing uh birth
control and abortion for for most of the
population
um and as far as I could tell the the
claim was that uh maybe in the long run
they increased the total fertility rate
by half a child
um so you know if that's uh if that's
sort of uh the best a totalitarian
government can do
um you know Paid Family Leave is just
not going to move the needle uh you know
I think Liz quotes somebody is saying
like the amounts we're talking about
versus how much it costs to raise a kid
you know the idea that a three thousand
dollar uh child tax credit instead of a
two thousand dollar child tax credit uh
is gonna suddenly uh reverse the trends
um just doesn't make any sense to me
yeah and I I guess there's that issue of
like even if it was thirty thousand
dollars I mean what
um you know and I I don't mean to put
you guys individually on the spot but
you know what would it take to put you
in the position of having more kids and
Liz you're actually you you have one
child and you're pregnant with your
second
um you know what would it take for you
to uh you know to have triplets or
something like that and I mean I don't
think there's any amount of money that
would make me have four kids that I than
I otherwise wanted to and I think that's
that's the big problem with a lot of
these most people these aren't decisions
that you can buy you know these are
deeply based on deeply held beliefs and
and values and they're not the kind of
thing that you can easily Sway With a
little more money they have shown you
know to be fair they have shown that
like some of these policies can change
the timing of kids they can make people
have kids sooner but not necessarily
have more
um and you know they get there are some
people that some policies might make
convinced you know it's not like
literally they don't work on anybody
like I'm sure that you know there are
families that might have an extricate if
they got free child care but it's just
not ever enough to make to make any sort
of difference except for on the margins
you know like it's not it's not making
any wide scale difference I know uh I I
believe this was my birth announcement I
was born in 1963 so it was the end of
the baby boom uh but um it it the birth
announcement it had a picture of the
baby with a diaper and a stamp on the
diaper saying another tax deduction
which is kind of you know a kind of
early natalist kind of policy right
um and but it I don't think my parents
took seriously you know the cost of
children or how much money they might
get out of it and I know in my own
experience and again you know we you
know we can't mistake this for kind of
data or or random controlled studies or
anything like that but the idea that you
would be able to pay people to have more
kids it's
it seems kind of
um you know it's it's just not going to
work and and Liz in your piece you do
point to a number of places where it
shows the timing of children uh you know
changed uh in some of these studies but
it really did not increase the overall
amount Scott what um you know is there
yeah talk a little bit about the earned
income tax credit and some of the other
tax policies that have been tried that
are you know considered uh child
friendly or family friendly and do they
have the the effects the the intended
effects or is it mostly kind of
rewarding people for decisions that they
were going to do anyway
know good research
um that that shows uh that they have
moved the needle you know in terms of
people that would have people that
wanted to have another child
um being
incentivizing them to have more kids I
think you know the child tax credit is
uh something that goes pretty high up
the income scale so you can be a married
couple making four hundred thousand
dollars
a year and still get the maximum child
tax credit uh for per child
um I I think there probably are some
families you know that switched from
being two worker families to being uh
one worker families and having a having
one of the parents stay at home
um that's a that's a sort of explicit
goal that a lot of social conservatives
have for the program I think
um but I I've not seen any evidence to
suggest that it's affected fertility
um the eitc the earned income tax credit
that you mentioned is more of an
anti-poverty program than the child tax
credit is um it phases out a lot sooner
it's targeted much more towards the
Working Poor
um and I don't know of competitive
evidence there that that has also
increased fertility but it does sort of
raise I think what ought to be a real
concern for a lot of the pronatalists
um who generally think that these
incentives are going to increase uh the
number of kids being raised by Mary
Perry since maybe it's going to increase
the number of kids and married parent
families with one uh parent at home
but to the extent that they target folks
lower down on the income ladder they
could also increase fertility uh in ways
that maybe they haven't thought about
non-marital fertility unintended
fertility
teen fertility
it really raises the question of of is
all fertility something that we want to
encourage the pulse he wants to
encourage and it's really relevant
there's good research showing that the
decline in fertility since the Great
Recession is overwhelmingly a decline in
non-marital fertility so it's it's not
that married couples are having fewer
kids it's that single single mothers are
having fewer kids
um over half of it is a decline in
unintended fertility
um so do we wish that we had had more uh
unintended births
um since since 2007 that's a big open
question that's a fascinating kind of
question too of like you know one of the
ways you know if you uh you know to
paraphrase Willie uh Sutton who you know
rob banks because that's where the money
is do you want to go back to a world in
which uh teenagers are having more kids
because
way down
yeah it's such a Triumph I mean I think
until about 1970 that it was typical
that you know a first live birth was to
a woman who was 20 or younger
um that has aged up and it also seems
particular with social conservatives who
are often obsessed with you know issues
of grooming and things like that we have
effectively desexualized adolescence and
young adulthood or or late teen years
um which would seem to be a win but then
it's like okay well you know why aren't
kids having more sex or more births it
it gets confusing
um very quickly what is the uh you know
what is the way to speak to people on
the left to kind of not worry so much if
we're not having as many kids as we need
in order to make Medicare for all you
know a glorious reality
well I think you know I think the the
the easiest message to them
um you know which conservatives would
immediately react to I think is uh you
know you ought to be advocating for just
uh Stronger immigration you know if
that's or higher higher levels of
immigration if that's your if that's
your concern
um beyond that I think
you know the the sort of to the extent
that fertility is something that the
left worries about I think it's just one
facet of a bigger sense of doomerism
um you know it's just another example of
like why the economy is failing
everybody and why we need Ubi uh so in
some ways I think
progressives come at it from a little
bit of a different perspective where I
think the main thing they're concerned
about is just how terrible late
capitalism is and this is just another
example of that whereas that the
conservatives come at it from like this
is a problem of of itself it's more
important than economics
and it's kind of fascinating that
Libertarians Liz are like yeah you know
I mean when you said like no amount of
money is going to move you to do
something like what kind of libertarian
are you you can't put a price point I
don't know I know you know I'm that
third child
uh it's funny too though because like a
lot of times I've been asked like
several times after reading this you
know like well so what if it doesn't
raise fertility like isn't it a good
thing in and of itself to you know make
lives easier for parents of blah blah
like you know this I'm this can't answer
that question like that depends on your
political values like the left is gonna
say yes you know we should give people
paid you know leave and subsidize child
care and all this stuff anyways just
because we should
um you know Libertarians are gonna say
no because the government's gonna muck
it all up and make it more expensive so
I think you know yeah like the question
of fertility alone doesn't settle
whether or not that is good policy which
is which is like a weird thing people
want it to settle yeah
um and it does seem I mean kind of uh uh
thinking about some of the stuff that
Scott was talking about you know it's I
don't think it's late capitalism I you
know since I was in grad school in the
late 80s I've been hearing about like
capitalism which after the collapse of
Communism became Advanced capitalism
announced back to late capitalism so
maybe this time it it actually is the
beginning of the end but it's certainly
the end of the entitlement State as we
know it I mean these you know Social
Security Medicare seem unsustainable in
any in in the current form they're in
and then the question is how much do you
kind of built the younger generation to
pay for the older generation how much do
you means test people out of these
programs and things like that but it
seems to be a kind of fundamentally
different question than just having more
kids
um so that you have future taxpayers um
which was Scott I don't were you
technically were you part of the
reformacon movement or whatnot but that
seemed to be a popular position on the
right to say you know what's good about
kids is that there are future taxpayers
and it was kind of this Grim uh human
calculus uh of you know we we need to be
having more kids because we're going to
need more taxpayers by the time I'm
ready to go on Social Security
yeah that was definitely I mean the so
so first yes I am a a living specimen of
a reformacon who will even own up to it
um so I think among them yeah the
reformacons are kind of like the Sith
Lords or something in Star Wars right
except not quite as uh successful or
ultimately deadly so that's good yeah I
think we're Associated fairly or not
with uh Jeb Bush and uh the the the
famous uh report after the uh 2012
election uh about how Republicans needed
to
um go after more diverse constituents
and ignore the populists and
um
had a had a very happy ending uh as we
all know
um so but the child tax credit I think
was the main thing that uh the reformer
cons were pushing and they were pushing
it I think with this argument that uh
the people who had kids were sort of
doubly taxed they were
um they were taxed themselves
um to support entitlements and then
because they were burned with having the
kids and raising the kids who would
support uh uh entitlements down the road
that was a second tax I I never loved
that argument
um but but it certainly was quite
popular and I think as we saw after
Trump was elected in the reformacon
group I think sort of splintered a
little bit into the the more pronatalist
social conservative side and others
um was that that there really was
um this desire to
increase fertility because uh kids are
good
um uh I think because we needed to offer
something to the middle class
um and it was in real tension with kind
of more libertarian points around you
know well if people can afford the cost
of their decisions they should favor
them
um I I because then the reformacon
argument too it was kind of like I don't
know what these kids just showed up like
you know the people who had kids there
was no sense of agency that well you
know what I chose to have children who
are a costs on society as well you know
and yeah down the road maybe they'll pay
in taxes and whatnot but obviously kind
of interesting obfuscation of like well
where did all these kids come from that
I now need more money in order to you
know live a life worth living
um yeah can I ask Scott for uh you know
for you and I'll go to you Liz after
that like you know on the on the kind of
more broad moral or ethical question
should the state be in the business of
saying you should have more kids or you
should have fewer kids you know there's
uh and Liz touches on this in her story
because of her population in China you
know they had the one child policy in
place for decades
um which is a disturbing you know I mean
Beyond disturbing you know Apparition uh
and it's similar to various kinds of
eugenics programs like you know but
that's a negative thing um but is it
kind of morally the same thing to say
the state should be geared towards
people having more kids or fewer kids
and is is the problem that the state
should not be putting its thumb on the
scale you know not not that it can
actually change Behavior but even the
gesture is is questionable
yeah I think that's certainly the case
um I I think you know what a very quick
way to upset
um a social conservatives to sort of
make an argument along lines of like
there are two families of each make a
hundred thousand dollars one of them you
know buys a boat one of them like
decides to have a kit uh like you know
we we should not it's not the role of
government or policy to favor or
disfavor one of those
um and I do believe that I'm you know
I'm a little bit uh more paternalist
probably than you guys uh in some ways
um so I think the
I think all the policy debate about
fertility is just misguided I think I
wish they were more of a debate around
marriage incentives
um and in part I can justify that
because currently government policy uh
disincentivizes marriage in a variety of
ways especially for for poor Americans
can you what are those and then uh yeah
what are some of the ways that it does
that so much of our
um our safety net programs are the
eligibility is based on
um family income and so this is true if
you take a job
um and your income goes up your benefits
go down
um but if you if you marry your
boyfriend or your or your girlfriend
um her benefits uh stand to go down if
she's getting food stamps or housing
benefits and those are are real those
are very clear Financial disincentives
you you can talk to people getting these
benefits and they will tell you like I
can't do that because I'll lose my my
housing subsidy
um so there are things we could do with
the Earned Income Tax Credit child tax
credit to try to counter some of those
disincentives that I would favor and
that I've actually proposed you know
sort of expanding their income tax
credit for married couples for instance
why is why is marriage a good thing in
and of itself why is that something that
the state should encourage rather than
be neutral on yep no I'm glad you asked
that I you know I I we were talking I
was talking about single parented
earlier like I've been a single parent
uh myself
um uh so I'm not somebody to sort of
finger wag
um but there's just a ton of research
showing the kids who grew up with two
parents do better on a you know dozens
of outcomes than kids who grew up with a
single parent on average
um I think uh people whose own parents
you know had split up or who uh or whose
kids have been raised uh separately are
probably you know that that seems more
obvious to them
um than it does to I think a lot of
people who are sort of like who are we
to say you know what what family
structure ought to be
um so so to my mind I think just for
kids opportunity for Upward Mobility out
of poverty for kids happiness levels
um you know encouraging more happily
married two-parent families
um would would be a good
it would also actually if uh probably
indirectly help fertility as well um
because one of the I think biggest
reasons although maybe Liz would
disagree with this based on her research
um one of the biggest reasons
fertility's declined is that people
marry later um and so they lose they
lose some years you know where maybe
some of them would would be having kids
and they might marry sooner if it didn't
disadvantage them in tax tax policy or
transfer payments yeah that that would
sort of be the argument yeah
uh Liz what do you think should the
state uh you know will you take a bold
stand right now Liz and say I'm
rejecting uh you know the the child tax
credit for my second kid you're going to
be a prisoner of conscience
[Music]
no
should you I mean how do you approach
that the idea you know and you know and
this goes to a kind of question of
libertarian paternalism I suppose where
people like cast Sunset and Richard
thaler said you know what there's going
to be incentives built into every kind
of policy
um why not tip them in ways that make
more sense or you know you know that are
that are kind of better for society
recognizing it's always hard to
determine that but should should this
state be encouraging or discouraging any
kind of family formation any kind of uh
you know kind of personal living
situation
I mean no I don't I don't think so I
don't think that's fair to prioritize
yeah any particular
um lifestyle over another because you
know those are matters of people's
people's values and choices or sometimes
they're not you know sometimes they're
just matters of circumstances and we
shouldn't be penalizing people one way
or the other because of the way that
they're either this is the date or the
way that their life turned out in that
um I do think this machine just you know
kind of get at one of the things Scott
mentioned about you know this is a this
should be a marketing campaign for
conservatives you know this should this
is this because this is a matter of
values and and the things you were
talking about with the 1950s too you
know like
um
I read recently that the divorce rate is
actually lower now than it has been and
I think like five decades and you know I
was saying that to someone a social
conservative recently and they were like
well yeah but that's because fewer
people are getting married in general so
like you know we're still investment and
I'm like yeah but but again like this is
how are we looking at it like do we want
people just to be getting married just
because or do we want people to be
getting married that are more wanting to
get married and able to be in happy
marriages the same thing with fertility
and I think we can argue that you know
because we have more
choice in these matters because we've
loosened these cultural constraints
around the idea that everyone has to get
married everyone else have kids the
people who are doing it are a lot more
stable are a lot happier are going to
produce happier you know individuals and
happier families and and better
well-adjusted children I think that it's
it's fascinating to think about on the
right there is a broad you know there's
a broad discontentment with the choices
that people are making because yeah no
they want I want people to get married
and have kids and and be younger or
whatever on the left that takes the form
of I just read a great essay called Ugg
capitalism where it was a critique of
left Wingers who just everything that
they dislike about the current moment
they just say oh that's like capitalism
that's and It ultimately
um you know we have these broad
ideological camps that are just mad at
the fact that a lot of people make Life
Choices or have preferences that they
don't agree with and instead of you know
for me I mean the only way out of that
for sanity was to kind of be libertarian
and be like you know you know we live in
an incredibly varied society and world
and that's kind of great and we're
bringing in more types of people and
sanctioning people to live and to think
and express whatever they believe and
that's all great and it means like
you're gonna you know you're gonna
encounter a lot of stuff that you
wouldn't necessarily prefer but it you
know for the same reason that they can
you know dye their hair whatever color
they want or live in a throuple or or
you know not get married it means you
you have a little bit more space to live
the way that you want and overall that's
that's pretty good
yeah this makes me think so of the um
the Catholic integralists
um you know that want the state to
enforce
um their their version of uh the good
life uh sort of it's somehow the thought
never enters their heads like you guys
are a tiny minority uh of the population
would you how would you like to see the
uh the the rest of the country uh impose
and sort of have the state impose
um its values on you uh which they
probably would argue it does to some
extent but but I think your point uh
about libertarianism is absolutely well
taken here yeah sort of the bottom line
in in all of this fertility stuff is
just that you know when what we've seen
in countries with like he hugely diverse
cultures political systems you know all
around the world and just all these any
difference you can imagine what we've
seen is that when you give people the
the choice to have you know the
technical ability to have less kids and
the choice to have less kids a large
percentage of them are going to take it
people are still wanting to get married
people are still wanting to have kids
but people are wanting to have smaller
families and that's right and it's yeah
it's also true that like you you know
you're giving people the technological
or the technical ability to have kids
who wouldn't be able to otherwise so
it's not just okay you know we're we're
not having kids it's you know people who
wouldn't have been able to have kids are
having them and that you know that
doesn't really get discussed very often
which is is a shame that's one of the
things yeah that I mentioned briefly at
the end of this article too is like just
in in a way you know possible bright
spots in this fertility argument one or
a population decline everyone
immigration but two yeah just technology
I mean we've seen so many people be able
to have kids that wouldn't have been
able to a few decades ago because of
things like IVF and other assistive
reproduction Technologies and as you
know those things get even better and
less expensive and you know egg freezing
just all sorts of things like as those
things get less expensive and more
widely available I think we will see
more people who are maybe struggling to
conceive now be able to actually have
children I worry about you know in this
because there's a parallel argument
about how you know there's so much data
we put so much data out into the cloud
and it's going to be weaponized against
us and I always think I had a Fitbit in
like 2011 I have no idea what happened
to the data it's somewhere in the
internet of things it's floating out
there but Liz that's like you know these
eggs when they you know when people die
or you know they're still around like
somebody is maybe in a thousand years
will stumble across them and create a
whole new race of uh super humans
yeah you know it'll be um Scott uh as we
wrap up could you talk a little more
broadly about you know the the debate
over fertility is one of these great
declension narratives that you talk
about and these are things that exist
you know apps I mean from in in human
history I mean certainly you know the
Garden of Eden is kind of you know Adam
and Eve are kind of it's the first
declension narrative in in a very
particular way within a kind of
Christian world view uh but in the
colonies the American colonies uh you
know certainly in the 20th century and
the 21st century we're Rife with
declension narratives everybody knows
only one thing which is that things
today are worse than they were 10 years
ago 20 years ago 100 years ago
um and certainly you know the decline in
fertility is always framed in that way
what is there an underlying Dynamic to
like when you go through phases where it
seems like people are more you know
declinists than they used to be
yeah that's a great question uh
I don't know that I have a good answer
to that I I think your point that it
sort of is always
there
um is right
um I sort of
you know my my limit maybe this reflects
my uh my age I was born in 1973
um but so I I sort of think of in the
1980s you know there were all these
arguments that
uh Japan was going to eat our shorts
um you know in the 1990s the recession
was described as this white collar
recession you know that was hitting even
the middle class and upper middle class
yeah the worst one since the Great
Depression yeah which turned out to be
you know about as right as you know the
she session
um uh from 2020 was
um you know and then there was like uh
the WTO and the rise of China and the
China shock and there's there's some
it's certainly true that that the the
China being a bigger economic power has
had some costs and it's had a lot of
benefits as well
um uh but but it's it's sort of just
this this constant thing that shifts
um Occupy Wall Street
uh and around the the financial crisis
and the Great Recession
um Millennials and the Tea Party if
we're if we're based yes the tea party
was a form of declension narrative as
well yeah
absolutely right so it it has it has
been around for a long time I think
social media has made it worse I think
you know maybe the Millennials have uh
maybe an undeserved reputation as being
especially whiny uh because like social
media was around for them to whine on uh
whereas when Generation X uh when when
Douglas Copeland's book came out you
know there uh it was just a book that a
few people read
um so I I I don't know what it is
psychologically
um you know we are inclined to think
that the good old days uh were always
good
um I think there's an element in our
media if it bleeds it leads um and and
so there's a bias there towards uh
pointing out all the things that are
going wrong uh and there's there's a lot
of bad statistics out there uh and a lot
of people who think their job either as
social scientists or journalists or
policy makers is to find you know the
problems that need to be addressed and
if you go looking for the problems you
will you'll find them one way or another
I know some of the stuff that you've
done at AI at the center on opportunity
and social Mobility is to debunk the
idea that younger people don't have any
upward Mobility or any options and part
of it you you mentioned a version of
this uh you know when you look at GDP
per capita rather than just GDP I mean
with Millennials for instance actually
are doing pretty well when you look at
Millennial income per capita and pegged
against where their parents were at the
same age so that you know the I I'm
becoming more and more obsessed with
what Irvin Goffman the sociologist
called the frame analysis that you know
we we are just applying the wrong frame
to so many issues um but then it becomes
that question and I think about this uh
my parents who were born in the 20s to
Immigrant parents grew up poor in in the
depression World War II they would talk
a lot about you know the difference
between 1945 when World War II ended but
they just assumed that their lives were
going to be kind of miserable because
they had been all along and you know
then there would probably be another
world war in 15 or 20 years but by 1950
that seemed to have changed and even
when you look at uh like uh you know the
black civil rights movement people it
was bad but people felt they were on an
upward trajectory you know the moral Arc
of History was bending towards freedom
and fairness uh and you know and even in
in my uh I guess young adulthood the
difference between 1979 or 1980 and 84
was amazing you know it's not that
people weren't complaining and there
weren't a lot of bad things going on but
the the general mood had shifted to one
of optimism I think this happened in the
90s as well despite you know Bill
Clinton somehow got elected by saying
the you know the mild recession of the
early 90s was the worst thing since the
Great Depression but by 1996 he you know
everybody was doing extremely well so
I'm curious what goes into those kinds
of big flips in a kind of social or
national mood
yeah I don't have a good sense of that I
do think the Great Recession
um you know was pretty formative for a
lot of Millennials and in some ways like
you know the the view of uh late
capitalism or whatever like the the
switch was never uh dialed back uh as as
the expansion
um under Obama and then under Trump uh
now under Biden uh has has sort of
barreled forward I think um you know
it's funny because we do a lot of like
debunking of these narratives too at
reason and whenever we do you know you'd
think people would be would be happy to
learn that things aren't as bad as they
seem in this horrible View and instead
people get really mad and really
defensive about it and it's always very
interesting to me that everyone sort of
clings to this you know things are worse
than they are view uh by totally like
unscientific speculation here is it
seems like you know for for some older
people like their lives are not as good
as they would like them to be or not
where they wish they'd be so so it you
know is beneficial for them to believe
that that is because Society has gotten
worse and for a lot of younger people or
youngish because Millennials are not
young anymore
um you know there's this sort of
Yearning to live in interesting times
and this feeling that like you know like
our parents and people before us all had
these much more dramatic you know fights
to fight and and you know just you know
just and we don't have that so people
want to have that and so they're sort of
obsessed with this idea that actually we
are in these worse times and it is you
know existential and we are fighting
Fascism and all this stuff because it
makes them feel better about their sort
of place in history or their own you
know self-importance even though I don't
think anyone would describe it like that
consciously but it seems like there's
some of that going on yeah um Liz you're
you are a millennial correct yes yeah
yeah
um what could you and I realize as
terrible to put you on the spot this way
but what how does the issue of climate
change or and not climate change but
climate catastrophe say how does that
fit into your world view and obviously
you're Suey generous to begin with and
you work at reason and whatnot but it
seems to me that the climate apocalypse
uh which is something that you know has
been an ongoing kind of narrative that's
been pushed and you know and I'm not
saying it's it's completely wrong or
whatever it's just that was a background
story which seems to be fading a little
bit but is that part of the the general
kind of milieu in which you grew up
where it's almost like no matter what
you do it doesn't really matter because
by the time you're 50 the planet is
going to be a burnt Cinder
online person or very highly educated
sort of certain type of neurotic
Progressive idea because like no that is
that has not only never been like my
sense but also like you know I'm around
not just Libertarians not just um you
know just I've been out of a vast
different variety of sort of
socioeconomic classes
yeah I live in real America yeah and I
just don't part of it all I mean yeah
people don't seem to really feel like
that's uh I mean it's not saying that
people aren't necessarily worried but
like there's not this like Doom about it
that but but I am always surprised then
to see certain people arguing online or
in in the media that like well obviously
Millennials aren't having kids or
obviously we're not going to do this
because how could we bring a kid into
the world with climate change and you
know yeah it there are people who
fervently believe that which is always
like I'm like wow that that exists I
remember an episode of All in the Family
it must have been in the early 70s where
Mike uh Civic and Gloria you know
Meathead Rob Reiner and you know they're
telling Archie like how could they pass
bring a kid into the world because of
you know starvation in China and the
Cold War and this and that and it's like
you know like there's always more
Arguments for not bringing kids into the
world right and it's never the right
time to have a kid right so but nobody
ever says nobody ever says boy I wish I
hadn't brought been brought into this
terrible world yeah catch me it's
Wednesday by Friday talk to me about
that at all I'll have a different
opinion but
um you know I guess uh uh you know Scott
of uh final question uh for you and then
one for Liz but in terms of the debate
over natalist policy or or more broadly
I guess kind of social engineering
through uh government policy and tax
code is that is that becoming worrying
to you I think you are old enough uh I
certainly am to remember when that was
the argument that conservatives and and
people at places like the American
Enterprise Institute would make against
Democrats and liberals and they would
say you know they are trying to do
social engineering through the tax code
or through public policy and that's
wrong has that changed on the the
broadly construed right and does that
worry you
uh I I think it I think there's been a a
rift that's opened up
um since 2015 2016 where I think you
have you've sort of seen uh you call
them the national conservatives or the
national populists
um they have adopted a lot of the same
critiques uh that progressives have had
for years now in terms of the economy
contributing to whatever whatever they
don't like
um uh about today it's sort of because
of features of the economy trade
immigration uh the financialization of
the economy uh that that need to be
fixed in service of of these values they
have that they believe you know are are
maybe more widely shared than than they
are I think a lot of that message has
been attractive to a lot of social
conservatives
um and so you've just seen the base of
the Republican party for sure which you
can argue whether they're Republican
whether they're conservatives or not but
um but but clearly that base is very
much populist uh it very much wants the
government's hands off their Medicare
and
um you know adopts a lot of these other
Progressive friendly positions I do
think there is I hope it's not a Remnant
uh you know is Jonah Goldberg uh puts it
sometimes
um of sort of more principal traditional
conservatives who are
holding fast to the positions uh that
were more common in the 1980s uh but
it's it's certainly kind of the central
split I think uh on the right these days
thank you uh Liz in terms of kind of
natalist policy and feminism can you
briefly touch on do you do you feel with
the libertarian movement uh you know and
I know uh you're one of the co-founders
and heads of feminists for Liberty
um which is trying to you know kind of
grow the understanding of individualist
feminism and whatnot do you
um do you find that
um do you find that that message is
growing or is there also I mean I guess
maybe it mirrors a split on the
conservative right of people who seem
people who call themselves a Libertarian
or are libertarian and seem uh
increasingly hostile to feminism or to
uh kind of you know increased autonomy
for women uh and the choices that they
make
yeah I I don't know if it's if it's
growing or if it's just getting more
vocal but like you know as sort of as
you said mirroring the display with the
conservatism it's been the big split
within libertarianism about whether or
not you know
Libertarians in their forward-facing
capacity should be tolerant of various
Lifestyles and you know sort of say like
yes the beauty of libertarianism is that
it allows people to live all these
different ways which is which is what I
think you know as much as you know a I
you know think that women's autonomy and
everything is great um you know I'm not
going to tell people like oh you you
need to you know live your life you need
to have your relationships in this model
you need to have your family being
raised in this model like I think that
that's you know an important thing that
everyone needs to figure out for
themselves but there definitely is this
strain of of libertarianism that's
that's getting louder that um at least
on the internet not not that I really
encounter in real life uh that that very
much believes like no actually like we
should take explicitly socially
conservative positions um you know we're
not necessarily saying the state should
you know mandate these but we should
definitely pick a side in the culture
war and argue that really strenuously
which I think is you know that obviously
Libertarians are going to have lots of
different positions in the culture war
and I'm not saying we should be quiet
about them by any means but I do think
that it's it's a bad idea for
libertarianism as a whole to sort of
make that Central to our project to pick
a side of the culture War you know
and I think that's one of the things
you'll find with just the feminist for
Liberty is that while we are stressing
you know certain certain positions we
are very much still holding the
libertarian line of you know it takes
all you know we want we want women to be
able to make their own choices we want
people of all dinners to be able to make
their own choices we don't want to force
these decisions on anybody yeah thank
you um we're gonna leave it there uh
we've been taught her I've been talking
with uh Liz Nolan Brown of Reason a
senior editor whose cover story is
storks don't take orders from the state
thanks so much for joining us Liz and
I've also been talking with Scott
Winship who's a senior fellow and the
director of the center on opportunity
and social Mobility at the American
Enterprise Institute Scott thanks so
much
I think many of them were still born
uh so uh you know I hope this was a
fertile conversation for uh future uh
discussions we're going to leave it
there please come back next Thursday at
1 pm eastern time when it's usually Zack
wise Miller and I talking and uh thanks
for uh coming out